hey what's up guys my name is china
welcome back to my game engine series so
today we're going to be taking a look
more of like an introductory look
at an nt component system and how we can
basically integrate that into our game
engine and what the big picture of that
is going to look like if you don't know
what an entity component system is
then please watch last week's video
where i actually
just drew a diagram and we talked about
what entity component systems were why
we want them
why they're better than just doing
things a different way
um i think that's really going to help
you understand
why we're going down this route at all
uh
and i mean there's a lot to say there so
just watch that video first and then
you'll this will make a lot more sense
so what we're going to be doing today
specifically is we're going to be taking
a look at an antique component system
called
entity or ant this is an entity
component system that has been around
for a while it's used by a few major
projects you can actually look at the
github repository linked in the
description below
to take a look at what that's all about
i've chosen to use an anti-component
system that
is not something that i've written from
scratch for a few reasons and i've
talked about them
i've talked about those reasons in prior
videos but to keep it short the reason
is because an anti-component system
is or at least a good entity component
system is something that's
largely complicated and will take a long
time to write properly
i know this from experience and it's
it's not it's not really something
i mean you can write a very basic entity
component system probably in a week or
maybe a few days or
however many hours you want to spend on
it but i've chosen to take
something uh else for hazel because
first of all um
i i don't really like i i know that an
entity component system is something
that is like we need to have a good one
for hazel that's just like there's no
way around it because otherwise we're
going to be quite limited
with how we use entities and my ideas
for how we're going to be using entities
and components
means that we really need to have a good
entity component system but also because
um out of all the things that i'm
interested in entity component systems
are not at the moment at least not my
biggest focus
i'm really interested in graphics and
rendering and all that stuff which is
why we're doing
that stuff ourselves but an entity
component system is not
is not like my highest priority and of
course as pretty much a one-man show
riding this engine
it would be very unrealistic for me to
dive deep into every
uh component that makes up a game engine
so maybe in the future if people want
and
if that's like a thing that that i get
around to
i might make a tutorial series on just
writing an empty component system
standalone
just so that um you people understand
better how they're put together
and that might be a fun little
educational thing but
i just know that end is going to be
better than anything i'm going to write
in the next few episodes if i spend that
on
if i spend that amount of time on it and
it's it's it's just a really good proven
entity component system so i don't see
any reason
for why we shouldn't use it speaking of
which let's take a look at it
so this is ant um i'll have a link in
the description below to the github
page here you can see that it is
mit licensed which basically means that
we need to disclose that we're using it
which is totally fine
um so license and copyright notice is
basically the condition here
uh there's you know i mean it's used by
minecraft i think the windows 10 edition
uh it's it's it's quite proven and it's
also quite simple i've been using it in
hazeldev
for quite a while now um so uh for those
of you who don't know hazeldev is like
the patreon only kind of uh
version of hazel that is like pretty
much a full game engine at this point
um that's been using ant for a while or
entity for a while
just to be clear i know that it i think
it's
technically it's supposed to be
pronounced entity but i'm going to call
it ant
and the reason i'm going to call it m is
just because it's a little bit ambiguous
if i say the word entity
it's like you might not know what i'm
talking about i might be talking about
the entities in the entity community
system or i might be talking about this
library
so in the future i'll just say ent for
this library
and that way it'll be less ambiguous
anyway i suggest
that you read the wiki if you're new to
this if you never used enter before
read the wiki because if you
specifically read the crash course of
the core functionalities
this um and there's a lot of like i mean
you should read this whole thing really
but this stuff will kind of it's not
even this there's
i think there's another maybe it's this
empty component system
yeah this is what i'm talking about if
you read this
this actually um explains a few of
a few of the design decisions
pay-per-use meaning that you don't have
to
um like you know as i mentioned i think
last time things that you don't use even
though it's a very big library things
that you don't use
aren't necessarily going to cost you in
terms of performance
um there's so much stuff going on here
you should read through this whole thing
i did this was basically my first point
of contact with the library
um it's it's written quite well and it
has a lot of really nice examples
so if you read this you're going to be
very familiar with this and everything
that i want to say in this video is
probably not going to be completely
completely redundant maybe because i'm
going to talk about how it's going to
work in hazel but it's it's going to be
you're going to know a lot
um so all we really need from this
we could uh get this library as a sub
module and add that and
you can see it like it it gets uploaded
it gets updated
fairly recently uh fairly frequently
like this was yesterday
um you know the single header file was
uploaded um
updated two months ago i believe that it
probably gets
uh updated with like releases and stuff
like that
my favorite way to use a library like
this because there's a lot of stuff here
there's a lot of stuff that we don't
care about is to simply
take the single include so we have a
single include here which is the end
file
now i don't know if this has the license
inside it
um no it doesn't so we'll need to
obviously take the license as well so
this is the license
um so what i'm going to do is basically
grab this end.hpp file and if you click
on
raw over here you'll just get the file
right and then you can save that as
and we're going to put this into if i go
back to hazel
and open the uh the hazel folder
in the file explorer and if i go into
vendor
and then i'll make a folder called ent
i'm just going to pop that into there
so let's copy this path pop it over here
and here we go we'll save it as just and
dot hpp
okay that's it um and in fact i'll make
a folder here called
include and i'll put it into there that
way we can just include that directory
and we should be good uh the reason is
we also need to include license files i
mentioned and the license file and
copyright notice and all that stuff
um i don't know if the license file is
included in that probably not
um there's a i don't really see the
copyright notice anywhere
um maybe that maybe just the license is
fine
um so if we grab this license file save
it in the same folder
rather up here i'll just leave it as a
text file
because that makes sense um that's it
right so this includes the copyright
that's it okay so that's all we really
need to
kind of use ant it's really just this
file it's really easy
that's the beauty of the single kind of
file includes and it's going to
enable us to have an entity component
system in our engine now how do we set
this up well
a few different ways um what i'm going
to do is i'm going to go back
up to the root directory and i'm going
to open the premake file and inside the
primag file
i'm going to add a directory up here
because just because we like we tend to
keep them up here because it's just a
little bit more
um it's a little bit better organized if
we keep them here i'm going to type in
end entity like this um
in terms of like how we want this i'm
going to put this
last just because like all this is
pretty much to do with graphics and
windowing and
stuff whereas this is like the entity
component system
i haven't given much thought to this
clearly um this is all i'm doing all
this live
so uh it doesn't yeah like whatever
maybe i'll change it
um and we'll just do n include okay and
then if we go
down to and you can like you can treat
this however you like you can put it
into a folder called ant
inside include so you do end slash
include when you do the or and
sorry and slash n.hp that's your include
path
um when you write code i'm going to
leave it as is
honestly uh and then in the include
directories
we're going to so we're going to have to
do two things we're actually going to
have to include it
in the engine like this right
but we're also going to have to include
it in the sandbox and in
well in hazelnut as well the reason is
it's kind of like for the same reason as
glm maybe the reason is that
um and again it's
whether or not you need you 100 need to
do this i can't tell you
well the answer is no you don't 100 have
to do this but if you choose not to
include ant
in your client source files then
things become very difficult because and
run and is a header library or rather a
templated library
so by basically by saying that you don't
want to include it in the client
you're saying that much of the library's
templated features
cannot be used by the client because
obviously if you're only including it in
the
hazel library then only code that has
has been you only code that uses that
those templates from and inside the
actual hazel library
that is the only code that will be
compiled from end which means that if i
come in from the client from my game or
from my editor
and decide to add a component or get a
component
or create a new component or something
like that i can't do any of that
because to get a component from ent i
have to have a function to link to
and if that's never been done in the
engine for example then that
function will simply never be compiled
and it won't exist and nothing's going
to work
so by including and in here we're
basically saying that even though we're
never going like
ideally we would never interact with end
directly i don't want to be using the
ant api
from my game we should be going through
hazel for that
for a number of reasons mostly because
we might be doing extra stuff on top of
ant that
you know relies on on those proper
functions being called rather than
internal functions which are what which
is what ant
is going to be but largely this is kind
of uh
you know this enables us to use the full
power of ant um
through you know wrappers and other
things without having to worry about
what has been compiled
what has been used what templates have
been instantiated and which have not
so that's kind of the reason for having
that in here
now um that's probably it let's try and
compile let's try and run that pre-mag
file
and then we're going to see if if that
helps and by helps i mean if we get so
in editor layer we should already have
access to this
now i don't think we have seen or an
entity class um we're going to create a
scene
class here if we go into core um we're
actually going to make a new folder
inside hazel and make sure that show all
files is checked and i'm going to make a
new folder here called
scene now this is going to contain
everything to do with scenes and
component systems components all of that
stuff right entities
everything will be inside this this
scene folder
so this is not just going to be the
scene it's going to be like all the
ecs stuff as well so inside this scene
um namespace hazel
class scene uh this will be something
that is
uh well it'll be reference counted but
that's not really necessary to talk
about now because we're not really doing
that
um h said p c h
and scene just some boilerplate code
here
okay so we've got our scene class i'm
going to basically
use this scene class to talk a little
bit about how ant
is going to work and to be honest it's
very very simple
um there's not even that much to talk
about but this is going to function as
kind of an introductory video this is
just going to be
a little bit of an introduction to end
in general so if we go back
out here um when we create a scene uh
you know i'll have just a default
constructor and a destructor as well
which we will fill up with
a few different things and then
ultimately what we want here and we'll
include
ends over here this is another reason
why we need to include it in client
because
we're going to be including ant in the
header file and really what we want to
be using is something called
the registry now the registry is
basically a container for all of these
components and entities
so entities the way that entities work
are entities are simply ids as i
mentioned in the kind of
what an anti-component system is and all
that in the previous video um
an st is basically an identifier that we
use to determine which components kind
of belong together in the entity
and a registry contains the actual
component data as well as the
entity ids that's what a registry is
there's a few other things going on
there as well but that's basically all
you need to know
now inside this registry so picture the
registry as like our
entity context it's the container that
contains our entities even though
entities by themselves don't really
contain much data
but that is what the registry is so in
other words the way that i like to do
this is to just just to have a registry
per scene
now if you need to uh you know have an
entity possessed from one thing to the
other you can copy the entity
into there um i know that ant
has some like
serialization snapshot mechanics i
haven't actually been using them
um i basically just rolled my own and in
hazeldev and the reason for that is
because
honestly i like reading the
documentation i just could not
like i spent about 10 minutes on it and
i was like no this doesn't make sense to
me
like i don't know how this works there
aren't any clear examples i'm not even
sure if this is the right path
um so i just decided whatever at that
point in
hazel devs like development i just
wanted this thing up and running and
serializing as soon as possible
so i didn't really care too much about
that but i know it has that so if you
guys want to do more research
and figure out whether or not that's
something we should be using then be my
be might be my guest
um but for now i haven't done that so
registry is like lots of features there
um i think there's even like a signaling
system with events so for example you
can cache events when components get
created or removed
um from entities and you can process
them that way there's a lot of stuff
going on
um so just keep that in mind so that's
the registry and that's the basis for
all of our
kind of entities in our scene so if i
create this stuff
let's uh we'll do a little bit of a test
here as i mentioned
so um upon destruction the end the
registry will be destroyed and
everything will get released
but uh we don't have to worry about that
because it's a stack allocated
registry object here so it'll just get
cleaned up automatically
so what i'm interested in is how do we
add stuff well it's pretty simple
we just create we just do registry
create what this does is create
it creates an entity and we have uh an
entity type that it returns
so there's a few different functions
here but basically we can just literally
do
this and i think this will return
an entity right and this will be our
entity so we've created an entity inside
and
great so what is entity and this is
again important to understand i think
if we look at what entity is entity is
an opec type
well i don't even know what this macro
does you know class class type blah blah
this is probably not what i wanted to
look at
um here it is so enum class entity id
type and then you can see the type here
is an
id type and the id type is an unsigned
int a 32-bit unsigned
int okay so that is what an entity is
right it's it's
it's called an entity right but
ultimately
it is it's this this is what we're
dealing with
if we were to break this down and we can
actually cast between them if we want
but that's basically it okay so again
understand that
and because of that you can't do things
like entity.whatever because it's an
integer
um instead everything goes through the
registry so in other words if i want to
suddenly add a component to it
i just do registry dot um
uh i think you can do insert there's a
few different ways
insert and honestly like i'm just going
to reference some hazel depth
because it's been a while since i
actually used nsapi because i have my
own
wrapper in place so it places what
we've been using in place um and then we
obviously specify the actual name of the
component
the entity that we're placing into and
then any constructor arguments
so let's just say we have a transform
component um how do we define components
like this that's it it's just a struct
there's no inheritance
like it's not like there's like a base
class that we're inheriting from
none of that whatsoever because we don't
want any of that that's just
extra noise what we want is basically a
structure of data
that's our component data so transform
component would have a glm map for
you could use glm map for itself but
that's a little bit messy
it doesn't say that it's a transform
component you could define different
types there's a billion ways you could
do this you honestly could
do it that way i don't like to do it
that way i like to define a component
called transform component
which has data inside it so let's
include
uh let's include glm this is what we
have here okay
a transform component a mesh component
would be the same thing it would have
mesh now you should probably make sure
that you
you know have a copy constructor maybe a
um a default constructor as well
so i would have a default constructor
i'd have a constructor that
you know we'd have a copy constructor
that kind of is just a shallow copy i
don't even think we need this we might
need this
um we could probably leave this as
default though
um like that is that a thing
yes it is um um i need to brush up on my
seatbelt class clearly uh
transform component const glm matt
for transform and then this obviously is
just going to set
transform to transform so this is like a
basically a little tutorial of how to
write a
uh component class right and then
destructor obviously we have a default
one we don't care about that
um so copying and copying components in
my experience i've used that a little
bit in hazel dev i think it's a good
idea to have
and then finally what you could do if
you really wanted to is basically
there are a lot of scenarios in which
you might want to use the transform
component as a matrix for example so
what i mean is like
maybe we have static void dude maths and
then
um yes i'm australian so i have a s in
the end um sumi
so we have khan's glm matt for
uh transform right and then obviously
this is going to do something with the
transform um
now if we want to call this function
it's a little bit annoying if you have a
transform component
uh so maybe this is your transform um
you know whatever
and then you want to call do you want to
call that and by the way just about that
little joke
when i write code i typically do
actually write it in
american so you might see me use color
for example instead of
that even though if i was writing a word
document or
some kind of handwritten note to someone
i would
write color like that so when i program
when i write code i usually
write i almost always write this like
this so you'll never see me write this
which is why it's not even realistic
it's not even a realistic
joke so for that i apologize um so if
we're doing some kind of math here
um then uh it's really nice for me to be
able to provide a transform like that
it's kind of annoying in my experience
to write code like this which is the
only way that this will compile at this
point
so what i tend to do which some people
might frown upon
is i basically have a an operator
that is my like operator glm mat four
right and by doing this and returning
the transform of course right
what this does and you can do whatever
you want with this
whatever right the point is this will
return your transform
um which means that suddenly instead of
doing this i can actually write code
like that right because i've written
this is like an implicit cast operator i
have no idea what it's actually called
but that's basically what it is
it just lets you implicitly do that cast
and in fact it probably lets you do it
explicitly because i don't think
that this will compile if i do glm
at four transform
maybe it will oh oops i've got this
yeah i didn't expect that to work
because that's not like obviously you
could type on it where you basically
you know do this and that will in fact
work
but that's obviously very messy and some
people will really frown up on that
so what i like to do is add an operator
like this to my components just so that
you know it's just that i don't need
that extra kind of level of interaction
like in terms of my code
i actually can just write code like this
and it will work because anything that
accepts
a um because since a transform component
really is just a map four
wrapped in this transform component type
um
it's essentially uh it's you know you
can use it in every way
imaginable where you can use a map for a
glm map for
so i like to do that conversion just
because it cleans up the code a little
bit
so just keep that in mind and you can
obviously add this is like a const
version
you can obviously add a non-const
version as well
um like this and visual studio likes to
uh
correct it like this all right um so uh
and sorry i meant
that oops sorry microphone um
there okay so now you have a
non-constant accounts version you can do
whatever you want with that
so that is kind of how i roll as far as
all that stuff goes great so how do we
get that
into the entity well it's pretty easy as
i said registry in place
we put in the type transform component
this is created on the fly you don't
need to register your components ahead
of time which i find is really really
nice
and one of um and great features um then
we provide the entity
where we want to basically place the
component into so where what entities
this component belong to
then we um provide the um
the arguments right so in other words
you know
you don't have to do anything that's
going to just use the default
constructor but you can also provide
your
glm.4 transform here so i can do glm
math for one right for the identity
matrix and that's it i've been placed a
component it's inside my entity now
and it's a transform component which is
initialized to
ident the edit the identity matrix okay
so that's done
that's really all you have to do um now
uh you know removing components um
you know there's registry uh remove
um remove as you can see will remove any
like a list of components from an entity
so you can do like transform component
entity like that it's gonna remove it
from the entity there's registry
um i think you can clear the registry
which is just going to remove everything
i think you can um what else is useful
registry get of course so i want to
retrieve the component now i want i have
my entity this is my entity
all right pretend this doesn't exist
it's transformed component well i mean
it doesn't there's no way
i think in place okay a place returns it
a few different things going on here
um so you can actually when you replace
it you can also return it also returns
it so you can immediately start writing
to it so i can say
transform equals glm map for something
else right now i'm changing the matrix
um so that's something that you can do
if it was like a mesh you can you know
do something to the mesh like get its
materials whatever you guys get the
point
it returns a reference to it which you
can do whatever you want with
however if it if you're in a different
function you just have the entity how do
you get
how do you get my entities transform
um you just say get transform component
and then entity uh and that's it
so this will return a reference to the
transform component
um so now you have i'll just write the
type so we're more clear
now you have a reference to transform
component you can reassign it you can
reassign the transform within it
um you can do whatever you want you have
that reference um
now how do you know if it has a
transform component you can do
registry.has
transform component again passing in the
entity and then that's something going
to trigger if it actually has that
component
and then finally one thing that's
particularly useful
is not just um checking to see if
a particular entity has a component
because that's this is all kind of
doesn't really need an anti-compressor
system but the the big
juicy part of this empty component
system which is why we want one in the
in the first place is
what if i want to iterate through all of
my entities that have transformed
components
so to do that there's a lot of different
ways honestly there are so many
different ways
the best one probably i think is to use
a view
now view and there's also a runtime view
which is based on runtime types if you
don't know the type at compile time so
in other words you can't use templates
then you can use a runtime view but i've
never had to use that yet um so
you do you just do a registry view
transform component
uh and that's it this gives you a view
that you just use like this
and then you can actually iterate
through all of the entities in that view
so this view consists of all these
different entities so now i have
an iterator going through all of the
entities in my scene in my registry
that contain a transform component so
here's a scenario
i want to render all of my meshes you do
this with your mesh component and then
you get a view of all the entities that
actually contain mesh components and you
just render them
simple as that so in other words if i
actually wanted to get it out here
i would basically just do the same thing
here where i do um
transform component transform and then i
have my actual entity here okay
simple as that um so uh
that's how that works now what if you
want multiple components so
going back to my mesh component example
we need more than just the mesh
component to render
a mesh usually we also want the
transform component
so to do that you can use a group so
auto group
equals registry.group and this lets you
group multiple components
so so basically you just do transform
component
and then in here um and uh and i'm going
to pretend that i remember this but i
don't
so everything's falling apart now and
i'm looking at hazel dev code to see
how exactly i've been using groups okay
get that was close get um mesh component
now we don't have a mesh component so
i'll quickly add it struct
mesh component oh we don't even have
meshes do we this is a 2d engine
whatever um it could be a sprite
that's it right so you basically uh once
you have that
um then uh you can and i think
for the view yeah okay um i think you
might be able to
is there a there's also a view get
function by the way um which i think
does the same
thing so you can actually
do this does this work yeah so you can
do this instead of getting
getting the it from the registry which i
suspect is the proper way to do it just
because it's probably more optimized
since you're only dealing with this
current kind of narrow view not the
whole registry but realistically i don't
like i have no idea what i'm talking
about but i can't i can't imagine it
being much better
because of the way that an ant is built
anyway
um and then yeah for the group we
basically just uh
iterate through the group the same way
as a view so we go through the group
here
and then just do group get and then
whatever you want and you can actually
um you can actually uh like you know
stack these like that
so you get your transform and mesh
component um and then the cool thing is
this works with c
plus 17s stuff so you can just do auto
reference
and then transform component so
transform
comma mesh right um and we'll get rid of
this junk
right and by doing this we can just get
both of them
immediately and that's it we have a
reference to the transform component
it's called transform
and we have a reference to the mesh
component it's called mesh we can do
whatever we want
we can be like you know renderer submit
mesh mesh transform or whatever and
that's basically our our
basic render loop for a 3d renderer done
okay so that's how it works
it's really simple um and
really powerful and really fast and
really good
so that's a rough overview of
entity i don't know if there's anything
else that i need to
cover um i'm just looking through some
hazel dev code but i think that that's
pretty much it
next time we'll obviously continue on
with this because there's a lot more
stuff to cover
but in terms of a basic introduction to
end i think that's about
it um keep in mind that uh
as i mentioned you can of course um
chain events and like
signals and stuff so you can do registry
um on construct on destroy on replace on
update for certain
uh for certain components so in other
words if we construct a transform
component
um we can literally do dot connect
to um you know like a function so we can
have a function here
called on transform construct that maybe
prints hey you
you constructed a transform component or
whatever i mean realistically you
wouldn't do that but
then you just give it a pointer to that
and i think
oh sorry that obviously needs to be uh
like that and then that's it right so
that's now going to every time you
create a transform component
this function is going to get called and
of course i wrote this with nothing but
really it's supposed to be something
that takes in a reference to the
registry as well as the entity that the
component was created on
so you basically end up with this um and
then
that way you can of course you know do
other stuff in the registry if you want
you can see what entity the transform
component has been created on
so many ways to do this for example like
so many uses from this i mean for
example you might be you might want to
catch
script events so whenever a script
component gets created
you might want to take this opportunity
to into like initially initialize or
instantiate the entity inside your
script runtime
now that you know the descript component
has been added to it um
so lots of stuff to do there and plenty
of fun
to be had anyway i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please don't
forget to hit the like button you can
also help support the development of
hazel and everything i'm doing here on
youtube by going to patreon.com
the channel huge thank you to everyone
who is keeping this series going as
mentioned earlier if you want to get
access to
all of this in action in like an editor
inside hazel inside a 3d world with
with physics now even um then uh
2d physics don't get too excited um then
check out the patreon and
you'll also be able to get access to
live streams of me developing
fun stuff like this thank you guys for
watching next time we're going to be
uh probably making like an entity class
of our own and
seeing how that integrates with ants and
how i've been using that inside hazeldev
as well
thank you guys for watching i'll see you
next time goodbye
[Music]
you